ce que vous avez à dos sur quelqu'un ou
parce qu'on fait un petit dossard ce que
pardon sur quelqu'un oui j'hésite à
parce que je sais pas passer l'aubaine
tous les dons session s'en fout or dit
je peux pas vraiment vous êtes vous bien
sûr regardez lille a dit le dos on s'en
fout bon ok alors balances ton pote au
lancement mais divine m'a fait des
titres qu'on financer quoi eu vraiment
mais nous rappelle ça à propos de cyril
non mr a exigé la présence de mon avocat
voila voila c'est quand même ne sais pas
si je pouvais le dire mais voilà divine
m'a avoué qu'elle avait un petit crush
pour vous serrer mon nom me font rire du
tout de tous mais kelly mais c'est ma
copine divine mais alors alors né du big
three bonne excuse le nez l'amicale
cyril un bon aussi samica des favelas la
nasa mittal senora sur ses week-ends
n'était pas amicale du tout non mais
attendez non mais y retourner
on est capable et de navarre on est tous
les deux voilà à bach et bien sûr voilà
ce à quoi bon se méfie mais qu'est ce
qu'elle veut celle là c'est sa demande
et la chine ça n'empêchera mais la
lorraine je plains votre frère et moi
vraiment si non non non un crash en tout
bien tout honneur
alors c'est vous dire alors moi je vous
trouve magnifique merci franchement vous
auriez pu être mon délire
approche celle et malheureusement vous
n'êtes pas mais ça tombe bien arriver
sous